Parkour is spreading so fast,...
...it has reached out to nearly every country in the world.
And as a result of this, different styles are popping up everywhere.
You know, I studied martial arts and media where I've met some absolute geniuses:...
...Parkour athletes who are studying biochemistry, designing new cures for cancer,...
...athletes who are studying philosophy, business studies, media; actors, stuntmen, even politics.
You know, parkour athletes who wanna fight the system.
Some people are here to compete.
Some people are here to express themselves.
Some people are here to just surround themselves with other parkour athletes...
...and gain our experience, and that's where I really like to be.
The fact that Red Bull Art of Motion is compact with so many athletes with amazing abilities...
...is that being around them influences your style again.
You can't learn parkour by just watching YouTube videos.
The fastest way, it seems, is to surround yourself with other parkour athletes.
But remember one thing: don't listen to what any of the guys say, don't listen to what anyone else says.
Just be inspired to figure it out for yourself.
What's next for Ryan Doyle?
I really don't know what the future has in store for me and I think that's the best part.
I'd rather not know.
It's just an adventure.